hello everyone and welcome to yet
another game from the round two of the
Greinke chess classic 2019 as it was a
very eventful round we are going to be
showing the third game from the round
and if I forget at any video
I mean after every video we will be
having at least a few videos from the
gringa just classic video teams so
always in the description below the
first few links you will see will be
either an interview with the players or
impressions from from round 2 so you can
also check them out now but you can also
wait until after the game to check it
out if you don't want your results
spoiled so without further ado let's
check it out Arkady night is versus
Peter Svidler it's a very informative
game I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it even
learn a lot so let's dive straight into
it
yeah night each goes for efore with E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 90 goes for the real opus and if you
check out the interview in the
description below which Peter Svidler
you will you will hear that filler
prepared for this as he knows that an IV
goes for the exchange variation of the
real Lopez so he goes a 6 more of his
defense Bishop captures D captures and
now just castles and here Queen to f6 by
Cellular we have d 4e capture son d4 and
now Bishop to g5 there is a one game
night is already played with the white
pieces against the boss Karen Audubon in
the 2019 World Team Championship in
Astana and the dis game follows this
game for a few more moves through their
moves we have Queen to b6 and now comes
Knight captures on d4 and here Audubon
went for Bishop to d7 in Astana in that
game ended in a draw but here's wheeler
prepares Bishop to e7 and it is of this
moment that we have a completely new
game on our hands it's a move 9 so it's
quite a treat
Bishop captures on e7 with Knight
captures on e7 and now Knight to c3
Bishop to d7 choosing either to Castle
kingside or Queen side we'll see how it
goes
Knight d2 e2 offering a queen trade and
sailor doesn't mind he he's up for a
Queen trade but he doesn't want to trade
Queens by capturing on d1 and developing
White's rook for free so he just castles
inside and he says ok you can capture my
but then I'm just gonna under both my
pawns fixed my pawn structure push d5
and all will be well and white of course
isn't interested first the Queen to c1
he wants to develop his Queen and the
idea is Quinta III and then well
threaten Queen to a7 which means that
the Queen will come to e3 with which
tempo nice the g6 by Svidler and now
Queen to e3 you of course don't want to
allow Queen to a7 fiddler goes we have
kicked the b8 and now rook a to d1
just a nice developing move also saving
time as the Queen is under attack Queen
moves to e7 and now f4 and white is
nicely developed here thriller still has
to figure out how to activate his light
square bishop and how to bring the other
look into the game and there are a few
ways you can do this you can go rook H 2
e 8 but fiddler finds a different way
first bishop to c8 he wants to trade the
rooks here and then bring the other look
over to d8 or ei 2 depending on what
white place he wants to play B 6 a 5 and
then develop his light square bishop on
b7 where it will control this ooh very
nice diagonal so this is his plan and
well white can't really do all that much
to prevent it
Knights the c1 knowledge start sorry
maneuvering the night with roof captures
as planned
rook after sandy won and now b6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop we have Knights the d3 and now
first a5 as planned he wants to play
Bishop to a6 but also also taking away
the be 4 square from 90s night and here
we have looked he won
we have Bush of the a6 and here comes
Knight to f2 also a possibility was a f5
here but neither G decided to go for a
different line Knight to f2 and here as
you're hearing the interview if you
watch it here's wheeler thought that
instead of a knight f2 F 5 was the main
move for white and he felt that this was
the the main line to consider after
night to have to he says that now he
feels at least equal but even might
consider playing for a win now and ok
here we have rook to e8 the finally
development developing this rook and now
you'll see that
swiller will try to pile up on the e4
pawn and also we do have a short footage
from this moment I believe it's from
this moment so let's just check it out
more compliments from the Greinke just
classic video team it's a it's a nice
footage of Arcadian idea ship and
pondering on this exact position so
let's just check it out very nice
footage there you have it
alright I do hope you enjoyed that and
here we have a three the problem is
Twitter will play f6 he wants to not
allow White's to push d5 and he wants to
bring this bishop over back to b7 he
will Riemann over the night and then all
of the pieces will attack the a4 pawn
the e4 pawn the problem is if you go e 5
immediately then Queen before and
there's no good way sorry to defend the
B to pawn so before trying something
like this neither she goes a3 prevents
Queen to b4
but now sailor just plays f6 he creates
a static center so white will not be
able to push a 5 and now white has to
look for a different plan so the knight
really doesn't have a bright future on
c3 non-id again rhe maneuvers that we
have Knight back to e2 and Bishop back
to b7 s planned Knights the g3 going
after the ef5 square and now c5 now the
bishop is finally free you know to wreak
havoc over the board Knight to a5 and
excellent square for the knight coming
there with an attack on the Queen Queen
back to f7 and now rook to d1 why stakes
now control of the D file but it doesn't
matter as filler now has to remain over
his Knight as well we have nice to f/8
c3 by white and now first a for a very
nice move as it will cement this B to
pawn it's it's a weak point it's a
backwards bone and sailor will try to
win it at some point by playing Queen to
b3 we have h3 by white and now Knight
the e6
nice back to g3 now and here comes
Bishop to c6 this is a this is a
wonderful move as you'll see it's a
multi-purpose move it still controls
this diagonal so we haven't really
ruined that but it also protects the a4
pawn
and it guards the d7 square because
after wife puts a queen under D file you
will not be able to do any any lifting
along the D file here look the D - just
a nice defender of the b2 upon waiting
to see what black does and here it's you
have to find the absolute best plan and
Svidler finds it for example if you go
something like Queen e7 just trying to
take control of the D file you're not
really gonna achieve anything
Ruby d8 let's say what can just trade
and this position isn't much better than
the one where you started to take
control of the D file so you haven't
really accomplished anything after Luke
the D - silver find a different idea but
you know if you like feel free to pause
the video and try to find the plant the
the game plan for black if you will I'll
give you a couple of seconds if you want
to decide how to go about it for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are once again an
excellent maneuver of knights and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show
once again the strongest move is a move
with the knight back Knights to d8 now
settlers plan is nice sorry not they're
nice to b7 to d6 and from d6 the knight
the bishop and the rook will all pile up
on the e4 pawn and after d4 pawn is
under siege white will have to use all
the resources to defend it then Queen b3
is an idea and white will have problems
defending both the e4 pawn ended the b2
upon so first we have Queen to b3 but
now you see the power of the bishop to
c6 move just Knight to Knight to b7 and
I will see that the bishop and night
here are nicely controlling the the
squares here along the D file out there
we have the nice and blue square so you
don't mix it up with these ones and the
white can't make any any Queen lists
along the D file so King th - white just
improves the position of the King we
have nice to d6 now as planned now
attacking d4 pawn and rook to d1 now
Knight ish plans to go rook to e1 so the
rook will guard the epon from there as
Siller is preparing h5 and H for the
people way one of the defenders of the
e4 pawn so H
five silver starts do this rook to e1
now the ponies here again protected and
h4 Knight goes back to f1 and now comes
Queen to b3 finally and here you have
problems you don't have a good way of
defending the b2 pawn for example if you
try Luke to e2 this doesn't work because
of Bishop to b5 you simply lose the game
this way on the other hand you might try
try something like Queen to d2 again not
gonna work because 94 now the queen is
under attack and also there's a double
attack against the b2 point you're gonna
lose it either way and lastly but not
leastly of course Knights to d1 you can
try to defend it this way and maybe if
the queen is attacked bring the Queen
over to be won but then you have again
different problems let's say Bishop b5
you move the Queen and now you get just
Knight capture sunny for you can't
defend both the B to Point and the e4
pawn so a very good example of how
silver exploits the principle of two
weaknesses 'if I've by white white as he
cannot defend the b2 pond he has to
create some chances so he starts pushing
the e pawn and creates the past keep on
F captures on e5 f captures on e5 and
now just queen capture something b2 it's
not just a pawn that fiddler one but he
also destroyed the base of the pawn
chain and now the a3 point becomes weak
and that the c3 pawn becomes weak so
what do you do here you can't go for
something tricky like captures captures
and captures because after King captures
you don't have any good follow up on
your well not not so tricky exchange
sacrifice so after Queen captures on B
to look to e2 was played attacking the
Queen and silver just goes back Queen B
5 and here if we capture then Knight
captures then C 3 and a 3 are under
attack you will lose another pawn and
then very quickly the game here Queen to
c2 was played and just moving back with
the Queen but now comes Knight to c4
an excellent square for the knight you
will not be able to get away from there
the a3 pawn is under attack and here
this is a move 39 and I teach is very
long one time he still has two moves to
make the reach time control but there is
no good move here you could try
defending the a3 pawn but it's not not
gonna work out very well here he played
east six he simply started pushing his
passed pawn and fiddle or just captured
nice
after sunny three the Queen is under
attack and well it was in this position
and move 39 that ARCA denied it you
resigned to the game so an excellent
game by Soler really really an
informative game really showing how to
exploit the principle of two weaknesses
the weak efore point and then after a
four has been pushed and B two was
created as a weakness just you know a
white could not hold all of it so here
of course white resides he's down two
points he will be down much more
material doesn't really matter what he
plays if he moves the Queen and then
just not be one you go after the c3
point you can push or pass bone here or
if you try something like Queen to d3 to
keep an eye on the c3 pawn a black can
just capture and after a captures Bishop
to b5 again you will lose a lot of
material here let's say rook a to just
captures captures captures you will lose
a piece here so pretty much whatever you
do you are completely lost here with
white yeah an excellent game but Peter
Svidler the game that it didn't even
reach time control so so far the only
players with who have won games are
across and who own both of his games and
sailor who won one game so far so it's
across and first silver second so far
and all the other in third we're not
gonna be showing the standings as it's
still very early in the tournament but
yeah that's it for this game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Joshua prim Kim Addison Pierre Alexandre
Wells lemma Mauro and Vincente
quintanilla for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it don't forget to check out
run to impressions it will be the second
link in the description below first link
in the description below will be an
interview with Peter Svidler about this
very nice game on the Greinke just
classic YouTube channel so do check that
out as well it's really enjoyable so
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day
[Music]